bonsoir nous sommes le jeudi 7 janvier
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour nous revenons sur votre
actualité locale entouré de nos invités
mais également des journalistes de la
rédaction
tout de suite on commence avec les
titres de cette édition un an après les
attentats de charlie hebdo la communauté
musulmane organise une opération portes
ouvertes
objectif échanger et lutter contre les
amalgames notre invité pour en parler
mourad dali président de la leaf
l'association cultuelle musulmane de la
ville d'elancourt et samedi aura lieu le
conseil d'installation de saint quentin
en yvelines
au programme l'élection du nouveau
président des vice présidents et des
conseillers communautaires le point dans
notre édition
enfin l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines fête ses 25
ans l'intégration de l'université paris
saclay et l'enjeu de cette année 2016
jean luc bussière président de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
reviendra avec nous sur le sujet et
c'est un triste anniversaire que nous
fêtons aujourd'hui un an jour pour jour
après les attentats de charlie hebdo à
paris qui ont fait 12 victimes
l'heure est au recueillement un an après
nous vous avons demandé votre sentiment
ce que vous pensiez et si vous vous
sentiez toujours charlie regarder je me
sens inverse mais oui toujours
parce que je suis pour la liberté de la
presse est la caricature qu'on puisse
toujours ce manque est tout dire je suis
charlie je sais pas trop ce que ça veut
dire enfin je suis solidaire bien sûr de
toutes les victimes je j'aspire à ce que
la liberté d'expression continue en
france charlie pas plus que tous les
autres parce que les attentats n'y a pas
eu de charlie faut pas oublier les
autres
oui parce que rien ne changeait on
essaie quand même veulent oublier de
temps en temps c'était pas évident mais
heureusement que l'oubli c'est pas une
support le passé du style sport l'a vu à
commander et l'hebdomadaire satirique a
sorti hier un numéro spécial tiré à un
million d'exemplaires publié mercredi
matin les journaux sont partis
rapidement à saint quentin en yvelines
mais sans attirer les foules comme cela
avait été le cas l'année dernière pour
le numéro des survivants de la rédaction
écoutez ce buraliste de saint quentin en
yvelines ils nous ont dit plus sur les
ventes de la journée
aujourd'hui donc on en a reçu 150 et
donc nous en reste 3 donc 147,2 vendus
bon c'est vrai que par rapport à l'année
dernière
on en avait eu 300 il me semble le
mercredi d'après don c'est beaucoup mans
mais il ya quand même encore un
engouement pour charlie hebdo je crois
que ça été retirés qu'à un million
d'exemplaires pour la france et je suis
pas sûr qu'on puisse être livré tous les
mercredis donc avant les attentats de
l'année dernière ne recevait trois ou
quatre par semaine donc là c'est vrai
qu'on a une vingtaine on en retourne à
peu près 3 donc on en vend 17
donc oui oui pour le moment les gens
continuent à acheter charlie hebdo est
en une de ce numéro spécial le
dessinateur riss à croquer un dieu les
vêtements tachés de sang avec une
kalachnikov en bandoulière comme vous
pouvez le voir justement sur ce journal
le titre un an après l'assassin court
toujours
cette une est jugé choquant pour
certains nous sommes allés demander
justement aux clients de cette librairie
ce qu'il pensait et leur avis sur ce
nouveau numéro
je sais ce mur aujourd'hui parce que
c'est faire honneur aux victimes j'ai
acheté à celui ci sur les dernières mais
du coup bah je pense que j'ai achetés
chaque année c'est vraiment je pense
qu'ils ont mis la première page
voilà ils vont un peu loin quand ça va
un peu loin
je suis pas forcément d'accord on peut
ne pas être d'accord mais je crois qu'il
faut respecter sa liberté d'expression
avant tout que leurs mines est très bien
on sent très courageux et je suis si
j'étais ici tu proviens continue
longtemps
ces inspecteurs anniversaire et que
c'est un moyen de se remémorer un peu
qu'il ya un an et les événements
tragiques et qu'il faut garder l'humour
malgré ses demandes et de notre
entretien de ce soir nous recevons
mourad d'année bonsoir vous êtes le
président de la leaf l'association
cultuelle musulmane de la ville
d'elancourt alors après justement c'est
une de charlie hebdo et la réaction
ce que je peux vous demander votre votre
sentiment justement si vous avez un avis
est ce que vous pensez justement de
déception qui a choqué certaines
certains d'accord juste avant en fait je
suis président de alif donc
l'association alif et c'est une des
associations cultuelles de la ville y en
a d'autres alors sur cette une
j'ai un peu le même avis que certaines
personnes on parle beaucoup de liberté
d'expression dans liberté d'expression
et à la liberté et la liberté c'est
aussi la liberté d'être d'accord ou pas
d'accord avec ce que fait cet
hebdomadaire très sincèrement c'est pas
un hebdomadaire que je lisais ou que
j'affectionnais particulièrement déjà
par le passé et je pense que ça a été
prouvé aussi par le fait que avant les
tristes événements de l'année dernière
il était au bord de la faillite
donc il y avait très peu de lecteurs
je fais partie de ceux qui
n'appréciaient pas spécialement ce qu'il
faisait
alors ce numéro là j'hésiterais je
serais plutôt entre le ça ne
ça me laisse indifférent puisque c'est
quelque chose c'est un numéro enfin
c'est un début de madère que je ne lis
pas particulièrement et on va dire que
le cheval de bataille de la pro de la
provocation c'est quand même celle c'est
quand même ce qu'il ce qu'ils appliquent
depuis un certain temps donc pas plus
que ça et vous respecter l'engagement
est justement ils ont le droit
il est en droit de faire ce qu'ils
veulent et on a le droit d'être d'accord
ou pas d'accord
justement après les attentats donc deux
paris aussi de charlie hebdo la
communauté musulmane française a été la
cible d'amalgamé aussi du dax non
raciste elle a décidé de réagir et
organise ce week-end des portes ouvertes
dans ces lieux de culte c'est également
pour les cadres ce week-end vous avez
décidé de faire cette opération qui a
lieu partout en france est aussi en
cours comment est venue cette initiative
en alors au départ cette initiative donc
c'était un c'était un projet qu'on avait
depuis un bon moment dans l'association
que je préside et les événements de
l'année dernière ne nous ont pas laissé
beaucoup de répit toute l'année 2015
il ya eu beaucoup de chantiers au niveau
de la communauté musulmane il ya aussi
eu le chantier de la mise en place du
conseil des institutions musulmanes dans
les yvelines le 6 me dont je fais partie
avec d'autres représentants de mosquées
au niveau départemental c'était un gros
travail ce travail là n'est pas terminé
il ya encore en processus de de mise en
place mais donc on n'avait pas eu le
temps
et lorsque cette proposition du cfcm a
été fait
on a trouvé que c'était une bonne chose
d'ouvrir c'est pas ses portes le budget
a précisé qu'en france oui le conseil
français du culte musulman
il a fait cette proposition
nous avons choisi d'ouvrir nos portes le
but de l'ouverture des portes
et surtout ce qu'on voulait faire déjà
par le passé ouvrir les mosquées aux non
musulmans ou à ceux qui ne les
connaissent pas et pouvoir échanger sur
l'islam et la pratique de l'islam par
les musulmans qui fréquentent la mosquée
ali file en cours ceci dit ce qu'on a
constaté comme vous l'avez dit c'est une
hausse des paroles des actes de l'isl
islamophobe
oui certains certains des fidèles ont
été confrontés et c'est quelque chose
qui n'est pas facilement quantifiable
parce que tout le monde ne le ne le
déclare pas il ya quand même quelques
fois des violences on va dire fille
certes certaines fois physique
d'autrefois moral par la parole des
termes tout le monde nous le répètent
pas nécessairement certaines personnes
sont tellement blessée qu'elle le garde
pour elle même je pense que la face
émergée de l'iceberg est déjà
conséquente
je pense aussi c'est que c'est pour cela
que edwy plenel a fait ce livre l'un
pour les musulmans pour la france parce
que à un moment donné dans les
différents médias dans la société
c'était on va dire libérer une espèce de
parole islamophobe mais comme si c'était
une forme de liberté
et justement vous vos finale peut-être
trouve que c'est une bonne initiative de
faire reconnaître leur religion d'ouvrir
les portes des lieux de culte oui oui
donc dans dans le fonctionnement de
notre association dont nous avons un
bureau directeur nous avons aussi un
conseil consultatif composé de plus
d'une trentaine de fidèles qui
fréquentent
le la mosquée de manière régulière
lorsque la proposition leur a été faite
donc d'ouvrir les portes de la mosquée
pourquoi pas début 2016 pour espérer
démarrer cette année d'une meilleure
manière que l'année précédente c'était
démarré en espérant qu'elle se termine
aussi d'une meilleure manière que celle
que 2015 c'est terminé on s'était dit
que c'était très important
il ya un proverbe qui dit que
l'ignorance est l'ennemi de l'homme il
ya beaucoup d'ignorance il ya beaucoup
d' amalgame qui sont faits le but est de
casser les préjugés et quoi de mieux
pour connaître l'autre que de le
rencontrer donc on propose cette
rencontre non musulmans justement nous
sommes allés à la rencontre des saint
quentinois et nous leur avons demandé ce
qu'il pensait de l'initiative que vous
proposez regarder je trouve que c'est
très bien qu'on puisse aller voir un
petit peu leur lieu de culte puis
discuter avec votre très bonne
initiative
comme ça les gens ont la possibilité
d'aller voir comment c'est exactement et
puis s'ils sont intéressés
ce sujet c'est pour rassembler les gens
je trouve c'est bien c'est une bonne
initiative
toutes les rencontres interreligieuses
sont bienvenus moi je pense que c'est
une bonne chose
effectivement que ça se passe la
conjoncture actuelle aussi ça peut
calmer tout le monde l'est puis au
contraire on est en période de paix de
calme alors on le voit les avis sont
plutôt positifs
justement sur cette une bonne chose
c'est une initiative qui va se se
refaire au cours de l'année 2016 vous
allez peut-être agrémenter votre
rencontre alors sûrement
et aussi je m'avance un petit peu mais
pas trop en disant que dans d'autres
lieux de culte ce sera aussi le cas dans
d'autres mosquées très précisément
l'association alif fait partie du
collectif des associations musulmanes de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et des
environs cannes 78 on se réunit très
régulièrement les différents
responsables de ces associations
donc même sur le grand saint quentin
puisqu'on a aussi les associations de
plaisir maurepas à coignières entre
autres et lors d'une dernière réunion
c'était une idée qui était vraiment
l'idée donc l'idée même pour être précis
l'idée même d'ouvrir la mosquée à tous
aux non-musulmans d'échanger sur la
pratique sur le lieu sûr aussi des
peut-être des incompréhensions ou alors
des raccourcis qui sont vite faits il ya
beaucoup aussi de deux problèmes de
terminologie dans les médias des termes
sont utilisés pas nécessairement à bon
escient ou quelquefois des termes ddte
désignant normalement des choses
différentes sont utilisés et peut-être
que ce sera le moment justement de
clarifier tout cela d'échangés donc avec
tous les non musulmans les chrétiens
juifs autres religions et les gens qui
ne croient pas voilà merci beaucoup à
mourad d'allier alors je le rappelle
c'est tout le week-end de 14 heures à 18
heures bienvenue à l'adresse justement
oui voilà donc c'est samedi
ce week-end donc samedi 9 janvier et
dimanche 10 janvier de 14h à 18h la
mosquée se situe sur l'allée des
bourrelier qui elle-même se situe dans
la zone artisanale des quatre arbres à
elancourt il y aura d'autres initiatives
qui seront organisées le week end
prochain et est le pellec le week-end
d'après par d'autres mosquées merci
beaucoup d'être venu en plateau d'avoir
répondu à nos questions
merci de votre invitation la nouvelle
agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines verra officiellement le jour
samedi matin les élus se réuniront à 10h
dans les locaux installés à trappes
ils seront dorénavant 75 pour
représenter 12 communes le point avec
wilfrid riche et une étape historique
samedi matin saint-quentin-en-yvelines
verra le jour et il ne sera plus
question de parler de la casse qui la
communauté d'agglomération mais au-delà
de ce léger changement de nom c'est un
changement structurel qui va s'opérer de
7 à 12 communes 246 milles à 230 milles
habitants mais surtout de 48 à 75 élus
soixante quinze délégués répartis en
fonction de l'importance démographique
de leur ville qu'ils voteront les
délibérations autour de plusieurs
compétences obligatoires développement
économique collecte des ordures
ménagères voirie ou bien équipements
sportifs et culturels
dans l'immédiat pas de changement majeur
à attendre pour les habitants au
quotidien c'est dans les prochains mois
que s'organisera par exemple une
harmonisation de l'offre des transports
ou encore des médiathèques
sur le plan politique la mise en place
de cette agglomération élargie se fait
dans un climat tendu
jusqu'à présent l'opposition disposait
de quatre vice-présidences ce ne sera
plus le cas au regard des tensions
récurrentes la majorité de droite et du
centre a choisi comme lui permet la loi
de conserver l'ensemble de ses postes à
l'opposition socialiste craint de ne
plus être associé aux grandes décisions
la réunion de samedi matin devrait être
agitée
toujours du côté de l'exécutif on notera
que la présidence devrait être conservée
sans surprise par michel laugier maire
divers droite de montigny le bretonneux
à noter sur le plan symbolique que
plaisir maurepas et coignières faisait
déjà partie de l'intercommunalité de
saint quentin dans les années 70 avant
d'en sortir en 1984 un retour aux
sources est un autre grand événement de
2016 c'est l'université de versailles
saint quentin qui fête ses 25 ans pour
nous en parler en plateau avec nous jean
luc hees vaissière président de
l'université de versailles-saint-quentin
bonsoir évidemment répondu à notre
invitation
alors elle fait donc ses 25 ans notre
université
c'est difficile de tirer un bilan après
1,5 en mai ce qui est déjà il ya des
choses que l'on peut retenir de ces 25
années d'existence
on a université de plein exercice comme
on dit dans le jargon qui a reconnu qui
s'est bien développée en termes de
formation de recherche de relations
l'implantation locale d'insertion dans
le territoire de partenariat avec
l'entreprise avec la elle agrandit son
rayonnement elle attire plus revient sur
wii fit il vous a pas échappé qu'on est
bons fondateur de l'université paris
saclay donc sa série
voilà c'est un signe qui ne trompe pas
en termes de reconnaissance donc
dans son complexe et rayonnant où on a
notre place justement les années
précédentes vous avez été confronté à
des problèmes budgétaires qu'en est il
de la situation aujourd'hui cette
arrestation est passé tout à fait donc
on a on a signé un petit peu la
situation
donc on a des bases plus elle donc en
conséquence pour pouvoir avoir une
nouvelle dynamique donc cela étant on a
effectivement fait enfin avec la colo à
la communauté à c'est pas moi tout petit
tout fait c'est la communauté qui a
accepté de dons de de serre fait un
sacrifice certaines restrictions pour
mettre la bia l'équipe budgétaire et
souhaitons remercier s'est pas endormi
pendant ce temps donc les projets on
continue quand même à émerger l'activité
a plutôt crue a augmenté dans dix en
termes de recherche par exemple ou même
de formation et là on a donc la
possibilité d'aller de l'avant et
notamment par rapport à la problématique
saclay où on a on a va nécessiter d'être
poids me différencier de trouver notre
place et de briller dans ce complexe
alors justement 2016 l'enjeu c'est bien
évidemment le fait de rejoindre
l'université paris saclay est ce que on
sait déjà ce que ça va changer pour les
étudiants est ce qu'il ya des
infractions arriver très vite la début
d'année ah oui oui donc puisque déjà les
choses sont mis en place dès la rentrée
c'est à dire en septembre 2015
oui puisque nous avons toute l'offre de
formation doctorale qui est sous le
chapeau va dire mutualisé dans le cadre
de sacré nous avons à peu près les deux
tiers des masters qui sont aussi le
plaisir à faire de s'appeler là
aujourd'hui on travaille à l'horizon
2020 sur les dix ans voilà donc
complètement où il se passe des choses
des jalles sur sac et nous étudiants
vont en carte d'étudiante avec marquez
pas et ça finit toujours par saint
quentin en yvelines bien sûr donc il se
passe vraiment des choses et ça avance
très vite alors le pôle universitaire
est immense c'est vraiment un pôle
d'excellence
mais justement cette mutualisation de 18
écoles des universités ne s'est pas sans
douleur on y lit à des difficultés qui
sont en cours justement voilà c'est bon
alors on est dans une phase d'apaisement
mais vous avez pu noter que avant noël
inattendu puisque la vérité avait une
date un petit peu butoir le 22 décembre
il fallait remettre un rapport par
rapport au financement
je prendrai en détail avec une
prospective qui posaient quelques
problèmes à certains son modèle de
gouvernance justement là après le modèle
d'intégration comment
la marque et c'est donc il ya posé
quelques soucis on va dire à
polytechnique pour faire simple on
finalement l'intervention de l'état
c'est-à-dire du présent la république et
du premier ministre ont permis au réseau
malien 18 établissements voilà quatre
ans voilà donc là on est 18
établissements qui avons signé sur la
prospective d'intégration moyen terme
donc raisonnablement donne un peu de
temps pour avancer puisque un objet très
compliqué avec des écoles des
universités des lives de recherche qui
relèvent de deux ministères différents
de la défense de l'enseignement
supérieur je pense quand même qu'on a
fait quand même une bonne part du chemin
et puis il faut prendre le temps
d'avancer comme 10 ou un collègue la
fameuse école polytechnique de lausanne
années 50 ans pour se construire
donc nous on est à trois ans donc voila
nous faut aussi être que le projet se
ferait n'y a pas d'inquiétude à avoir
non moi je suis plutôt optimiste après
il faut prendre un peu de temps ça ira
pas ça pas se faire en quatre ans voilà
c'est très bien donc ça a quand même un
projet très ambitieux et voilà donc ça
prend un peu de temps et je suis très
contente l'état intervienne et soit
présent pour nous accompagner pour nous
aider justement la prochaine étape pour
cette intégration l'univers ton de la
prochaine étape donc je vous lis et à
l'heure on travaille sur l'intégration à
moyen terme se dit alors à l'horizon
2019 2020 de tout ce qui est l'offre de
formation en licence développée après
les partenariats de recherche développer
la mutualisation sur d'autres fonctions
comme les relations internationales de
développer de travailler sur la terre ou
la pluridisciplinarité parce qu'on a
aujourd'hui un petit peu de structures
disciplinaires dont je pense qu'il ya
plein de choses à faire ensemble entre
les disciplines que ce soit du droit
avec une science etc
donc il ya un chantier assez important
non je pense est important d'être sur le
terrain travailler sur la formation sur
la recherche sur les partenariats avec
les industries avec les collectivités et
la gouvernance ça vient après enfin une
dernière question avant d'une entité
s'il ya des initiatives exceptionnelles
qui sont prévues pour les 25 ans donc on
en train de réfléchir effectivement
exceptionnel je sais pas ce système on
ne s'est effectivement de marquer ses 25
ans qui devrait arriver au printemps
2016 dont on notera de réfléchir sur des
initiatives pour mettre en valeur donc
le lait
mission lunaire citer que ce soit en
recherche la formation mais également
les initiatives étudiantes donc là on
entend construire des événements sur
l'année 2016 très bien merci beaucoup je
ne vais sert d'être venu et d'avoir
répondu à nos questions
l'espace yves montand du centre social
du pont du routard de guyancourt rend
hommage à l'une des voies essentielles
de la poésie du 20e siècle
aimé césaire poète homme politique et
humaniste une exposition jusqu'au 16
janvier prochain pour découvrir la vie
et l'oeuvre de cette anticolonialiste
résolu
un travail mené par djamel brave un
responsable du centre social axé autour
du vivre ensemble et de l'accès à la
culture on les écoute pour le centre
social ça d'autant plus ceux de deux
sens que aimé césaire
c'est parti d'une famille qui n'avait
pas grand chose et que
il a pu développer
et créer pas mal de productions
littéraires par rapport à son parcours
lié à l'instruction
voilà et donc c'est un formidable
message qu'on passe aussi gérer aux
jeunes des quartiers en leur disant que
par l'instruction peut arriver à faire
beaucoup de choses et nous recevons à
présent sur ce plateau notre journaliste
sportif est michael et demi d'euros pour
la chronique sport du jeudi la première
de l'année
bonsoir michael je vous souhaite une
bonne année est aussi merci vous avez
passé de bonnes fêtes
évidemment pas ces soucis du sport
évidemment vient de me tient évidemment
à leur père sera le thème de votre
première chronique de l'année 2016 ba
aujourd'hui coup de projecteur sur
l'euro de football 2016 la compétition
sera organisée en france du 10 juin au
10 juillet le département des yvelines
va servir de camp de base à 3 équipes
nationales l'équipe de france sera
installé à clairefontaine l'équipe de
russie sera croissy sur seine et les
irlandais emmenés par l'intenable
attaquant robbie keane sont à versailles
pour nous parler de la cité royale nous
recevons sur ce plateau jean marc
fresnel adjoint au maire délégué aux
sports à la ville de versailles bonsoir
bonsoir
alors comment avez vous réagi quand vous
avez appris que les irlandais allait
arriver à versailles très très
agréablement parce que depuis plusieurs
mois donc nous avions posé notre
candidature notre l'uefa nous avait
proposé d'être possibilité de camp de
base en à mesure ou versailles pouvait
avoir
nous avions un terrain et un lieu
d'accueil agréable pour les équipes et
puis bien sûr versailles étant une ville
attrayante et une structure hôtelière
kid et qui convenait
on a eu plusieurs visites plusieurs
temps plusieurs équipes qui sont venus
nous voir afin d'élever qui alors
l'unique est pas acquis malheureusement
je pense qu'elle aurait devrait été au
bout mais c'étaient les hollandais donc
qui n'ont pas pu se qualifier donc donc
après on attendait un petit peu on est
des russes les russes qui sont passés
faible bise et craignent un dessin ya
d'abord les russes les turcs qui se sont
bien gardés en scène dans l'adoption pas
loin etc
et puis les irlandais lors ça s'est fait
un petit peu sur le tard je pense qu'il
avait un petit peu
gardez cette cette possibilité à
versailles ça s'est fait surtout lorsque
les tirages au sort ont été effectués et
en barrages
voilà exactement ma rage d'une part et
ensuite dans la poule des matches du
mois de juin ils seront ils joueront à
paris à lille et à bordeaux de mémoire
dont qui convenait d'avoir un lieu
central qui était à paris
enfin en région parisienne alors qu'au
départ il avait pris une option sur
dijon et donc finalement ça s'est fait
très vite ça s'est fait très vite je
pense qu'ils avaient bien vu il
connaissait notre cahier des charges et
connaissez nos installations
puis sont venus nous voir dans le mois
de décembre on a très rapidement conclu
possibilité de les recevoir puisque
correspondait à ce qu'ils attendaient et
ils ont quelques exigences mais qui sont
pour nous relativement secondaire par
rapport à la modification des
installations enfin la mise en place des
structures pour eux et donc le dossier
comprend le stade mont boron de
versailles et donc le trianon palace
finalement les deux infrastructures ont
fait pencher la balance
peut-être de votre côté vous annonçait
récemment des rénovations instamment
brouillard j'irai aussi à un petit peu
une histoire puisque 98 des hollandais
était venu en 2007 ses polo rugby
les anglais donc en fait il y avait
quand même une habitude de venir et sur
ces deux structures notre stade était
intéressant parce que il a bon bien sûr
les dimensions il n'est pas très utilisé
puisque il n'utilisait que le terrain
n'est utilisé que par l'équipe de
versailles qui joue en dh
donc il est en très très bon état et
puis il est facilement faire ensemble
on isole place il est très bien que la
zone est donc il n'ya pas de vie des
centrales
donc en fait il est vraiment très
attirant et en plus ça a été un petit
peu en plus du cahier des charges on
aura un mètre on va mettre à disposition
un centre de presse qui sera un des
gymnases qui sont maintenant au terrain
donc en fait ça nous permet d'avoir sur
le même lieu à la fois l'équipe sportive
est à la fois la réception de la presse
puisque ils ont prévu seulement une
centaine de journalistes dont vous en
permanence et dans 13 ans présent sur le
site web et cela prouve également qu'il
disait tout à l'heure les pays bas sont
venus en 98 l'angleterre pour la coupe
du monde de rugby en 2007 versailles
veut vraiment s'associe au grand
événement sportif de l'année ans quand
la france organise à oui je pense que
falla versailles justement notre vision
avec avec force aux nazis hier le maire
c'est de montrer que versailles et bien
sûr est une ville attaché d'histoire
attaché à sa son ancienneté à sa culture
et le dynamisme culturel qu'il ya autour
de la ville de versailles mais associé à
cela il ya la jeunesse il ya des parts
de l'université de 51 tout d'ailleurs
d'implanter ou servir ça y est
donc en fait de montrer aussi qu'à
versailles il ya d'autres dynamiques et
notamment la dynamique sportive
alors après ça fait un peu boule de
neige parce que du coup à proposer un
site comme versailles s'appelait aux
fédérations bien évidemment on en
parlera peut-être en fin de sujet pour
pour un autre événement est
effectivement c'est assez facile de
pouvoir s'y associer et manger avec le
maire vraiment souhaitée
depuis plusieurs années on sait qu'on a
eu le tour de france la dernière
question très rapide est-ce que des
animations des animations vont être
proposées ou versailles et aux idées
noires oui on va on verra un petit peu
on va construire l'événement alors un
petit peu contraint pour des raisons de
sécurité aujourd'hui et de fermeture des
installations donc on verra quelles
étaient nos deux possibilités d'abord
associé la ville je pense qu'il faut que
les irlandais soit accueilli parce que
il ya beaucoup d'irlandais dans notre
région donc il y aura des gens qui
auront envie de voir leurs joueurs
et puis également moi ce que je souhaite
c'est que l'on puisse avoir des moments
portes ouvertes avec les enfants avec
les écoles avec les écoles de football
pourquoi pas imaginer un match le club
de versailles contre une équipe
irlandaise monter peut-être autour de
jeu c'est pas de l'euro à quelque chose
de faire un petit peu un événement phare
un espèce de mini fons irlande aux
couleurs de notre de notre équipe merci
à vous d'être passé sur ce plateau on
n'hésitera pas à venir versailles pour
filmer les irlandais un stade mont boron
tacle merci beaucoup
on passe maintenant l'agenda sport du
week-end on commence par des commissions
et deux courts couverts du parc philippe
cousteau de la verrière vont accueillir
à partir de ce samedi à plus de 140
joueurs amateurs et classé à l'occasion
de l'open de tennis de la ville
le spectacle devrait donc être au
rendez-vous cette 13ème édition est
programmée sur trois semaines et des
semaines s'affronteront du 9 au 31
janvier
on continue à votre chronique par du
rugby un choc qui ne faudra pas rater
dans le nord du département
en promotion d'honneur le sky rugby se
déplacera sur le terrain de l'entente
triel les mureaux pour le compte de la
10e journée du championnat
le match est programmé ce dimanche à 15
heures au stade gaston chirac les saint
quentinois doivent remporter ce match
pour conserver la première place du
classement une place de leader acquise
grâce à une victoire contre clermont
lors de la 8e journée
le sky partira favori contre les mureaux
les joueurs coachés par thomas payen les
avait dominés 26 à 3 en octobre dernier
termine rapidement parce que nous sommes
un petit peu en retard michael part de
football avec les voisins mon équipe
préférée qu'il faut on jouera ce
dimanche donc sur les terrains de
division excellence l'équipe senior de
maurepas or soit possible ce dimanche à
15 heures pour un derby qui s'annonce
sulfureux pour la lutte pour le maintien
avec une victoire contre kouassi
maurepas pourrait s'emparer de la 6e
place du classement les supporters sont
évidemment invités à les soutenir
vous êtes maintenant incollable sur les
rendez-vous du week-end floral
si beaucoup et mickaël c'est la fin de
cette édition merci de nous avoir suivis
alors restez avec nous car bientôt vous
avez rendez vous avec michael elle me
d'euros pour son talk-show si on parlait
sport entouré de ses chroniqueurs
alors il sera question de la
qualification de menton 16e de finale de
coupe de france du jeune prodige de
cartes où liam bertrand originaire du
chesnay également demain vous retrouvez
à wilfrid de réchy pour l'essentiel de
l'actu du vendredi quant à moi je
retrouve lundi
je vous souhaite donc un très bon
week-end et une bonne soirée